[Musique]
bonjour Jacqueline stage brigot merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin et de
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu du valdoise
membre du groupe les républicain et
membres de la commission d'enquête sur
les menaces et agressions contre les
enseignants dont on va parler puisque
vous avez auditionné hier la se la sœur
de Samuel paatti mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est du côté d'Israël où
une frappe a touché hier soir à un
hôpital euh à Gaza Israël qui accuse le
Hamas Israël qui accuse pardon le Jihad
islamique le Hamas qui dit que c'est
Israël qui a frappé est-ce que il faut
craindre une escalade et un embrasement
oui enfin je pense que nous sommes tous
tous tous inquiets de ce qui se passe en
Israël ça c'est évident après
euh c'est aussi le jeu des islamistes
que d'accuser Israël euh que de ne pas
accepter que cela pourrait être le
djihad islamiste qui est tout à fait
capable de faire ça justement pour
briller les cartes donc il faut être
extrêmement vigilant sur ce qui va se
passer dans les heures qui viennent euh
mais il faut pas se tromper quand le
Hamas a attaqué Israël parce que c'est
juste ça qui s'est passé il faut pas
oublier qu'il y a eu un agresseur et un
agressé le Hamas savait très bien qu'il
allait avoir des conséquences
géopolitiques dans cette partie du monde
mais dans le monde
dramatique c'est voilà donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le combat il est amené
pour la liberté quand on attaque Israël
on attaque une démocratie on
attaque nos valeurs aussi et on a on
nous attaque nous aussi quelque part
voilà donc ce ce ce conflit évidemment
inquiétant ce conflit va nous interroger
longtemps mais c'est un conflit qu'il
faut regarder avec objectivité et il
faut juste voir où sont nos ennemis nos
ennemis ce sont les islamistes ce sont
les ennemis du monde et ce sont les
ennemis pour l'équilibre du monde donc
faut pas oublier ça il faut pas oublier
ça voilà c'est nos nos sociétés
occidentales qui sont menéassz à travers
ces combats et à travers ce qu'a fait le
Hamas vraiment il y a eu des des
manifestations dans plusieurs pays il y
a eu notamment des manifestations devant
l'ambassade de France à Tunis suite à ce
tir sur un un hôpital de Gaza avec des
slogans hostiles à la France hostile à
Emmanuel Macron alliés des sionistes
c'est ce que disaient les manifestants
qu'en dites-vous je suis extrêmement
scandalisé par ces propos-là et
extrêmement scandalisé que dans des pays
voilà avec lequels on a des relations
tical depuis longtemps on puisse
accepter que ce genre de manifestation a
lieu la France elle est juste une
démocratie qui défend la démocratie et
la société occidentale telle que nous
nous dans dans laquelle nous vivons je
veux
dire nos ennemis sont aussi celles et
ceux qui souhaitent avoir des
théocraties dans les pays il y a rien de
pire et donc c'est vrai que ça me choque
énormément énormément que ce genre de
manifestation a lieu vraiment alors ça
prouve aussi peut-être que la France est
affaiblie à travers le monde hein ça
c'est un autre sujet mais c'est une
réalité aussi plusieurs sénateurs les
républicains du centre souhaiter que
soit mis à l'ordre du jour du Sénat ce
soir une résolution pour condamner les
crimes du Hamas pour soutenir les
Israéliens le gouvernement a refusé de
mettre ce texte à l'ordre du jour
qu'est-ce que ça traduit selon vous
d'abord vous avez vu que ça a provoqué
une énorme colère du président Larcher à
juste titre je trouve que ça traduit un
manque de courage je veux dire ne pas
autoriser l'inscription de de de ce
sujet cet après-midi au Sénat c'est
juste de pour moi de la faiblesse c'est
de la faiblesse et on le courage de dire
pour qui nous nous battons comment nous
nous battons et pourquoi nous nous
battons et là vraiment enfin je je ne
parle évidemment pas à la place du
président Larché mais je comprends la
colère du président Larcher et je ne
comprends pas l'attitude du kedorset
parce que cette faiblesse là elle nous
tue hier la députée la France insoumise
Daniel obono a une autre fois de plus
une nouvelle fois pardon refuser de
qualifier le Hamas d'organisation
terroriste et parler de mouvement de
résistance est-ce que Gérald Arman a eu
raison saisir la justice pour apologie
du terrorisme mais totalement totalement
on peut pas on peut pas reprocher au
ministre de d'avoir entamé cette
démarche de toute façon
auono et et ses amis sont les amis des
islamistes d'accord et le
clientélisme avec
l'islamisme amène à ce qu'on tue notre
démocratie et notre liberté je le dis
clairement s'allier avec les islamistes
où où que ce soit en France so ailleurs
c'est tuer la démocratie c'est tuer
notre liberté donc pas de compromission
donc oui ce qu'elle a dit est grave ce
que elle est fini est grave et nous et
cette démarche qu' entamé gérardtin est
tout à fait légitime normale et moi je
ne peux que la soutenir ils sont plus
dans l'arc républicain pour vous mais
plus du tout plus du tout enfin je veux
dire c'est et par clientélisme
uniquement et ce clientélisme je le
redis le clientélisme avec les
islamistes nous tue il y a eu près de
200 interpellations pour des actes
antisémites de depuis samedi dernier
depuis le début depuis l'attaque du
Hamas est-ce que c'est le signe que
l'importation du conflit est là dans
notre pays il est là mais il est pas là
depuis hier il est pas là depuis la
semaine dernière vous savez il y a eu un
électrochoc pour ce sur ça avec les
tours de New York en 2001 on n'a pas
voulu voir vous savez dès quand les
attentats ont lieu à New York un certain
nombre de jeunes d'ici se sont
identifiés à Benladen et à la cause Ben
Laden et au mouvement de Ben Laden déjà
là on n' pas voulu le dire on n' pas
voulu le poser et on n' pas voulu voir
que ça allait s'inscrire avec le temps
dans nos quartiers dans nos villes et
dans notre pays et on s'est généralisé
pour vous oui je pense que c'est tout le
monde Gérard Larché la semaine dernière
il disait que la classe politique avait
fait il y avait eu des des faiblesses
dans la lutte contre alors moi je me
sens pas concernée par cette phrase
parce que j'ai toujours dénoncé vous le
savez depuis je suis au Sénat je ne fais
que ça et et et dans ma propre viine je
l'ai fait aussi donc moi je je suis très
à l'aise avec ça parce que j'ai fait
partie viment des élus qui ont ouvert
les yeux assez tôt d'ailleurs j'ai pas
souvent été suivi parce qu'on disait que
j'exagérais un peu je pense que je
n'exagérais pas oui c'est-à-dire que ce
côté on va pas bousculer on va pas y
compris la presse à l'époque moi j'ai
échangé avec des journalistes sur ce
sujet qui ont avoué un jour
oui mais nous on voulait pas trop aller
dans ce sens-là parce qu'on voulait pas
et c'est cette phrase elle est
importante on ne voulait pas pas du
donner du crédit à Marine Le Pen il y a
20 ans d'accord enfin au mouvement de
Marine Le Pen et on s'était et du coup
non seulement on n'a pas dénoncé
l'horreur et on n' pas voulu voir ce qui
s'installait dans notre pays mais Marine
le Marine Le Pen est au porte du pouvoir
donc voilà donc c'est une responsabilité
collective avec effectivement B une
gauche qui est un peu bisounours quand
même qui aujourd'hui B on voit où ils en
sont hein c'est pire que nous donc ou
elle a été trop faible notamment sur ces
questions de sécurité de lutte contre
oui oui parce que la gauche quand même
pendant des annéesous mais c'est quoi
c'est du laxisme ou c'est de l'angélisme
les deux les deux et l'angélisme
regardez où il nous mène vraiment et
puis vous savez nos ennemis jouent avec
notre faiblesse parce que c'est nos
faiblesses notre faiblesse en général
qui donne du crédit à à ceux qui qui qui
effectivement sont les ennemis de notre
liberté de la République et donc c'est
nos faiblesses qui qui qui qui
impliquent leur force vraiment est-ce
que aujourd'hui vous avez l'impression
quand vous entendez le gouvernement que
il y a une volonté justement de ne plus
être faible d'être plus ferme C
questions un peu tard clairement tard ah
oui on voit bien les propos de de de du
ministre ataliè ont été très clair à
l'Assemblée mais c'est tard c'est très
tard on en a perdu des années et du coup
est-ce que c'est trop tard pour vous ou
est-ce que ce combat il est encore g je
je refuse de dire que c'est trop tard
parce que parce que je suis d'une nature
positive optimiste mais je suis quand
même très inquiète vraiment vraiment et
et pour pour pouvoir vous répondre ce
n'est pas trop tard ça veut dire que de
manière à forte ferme il va falloir
écrire des choses mais de manière rapide
et forte lesquels il faut alors c'est
c'est c'est notre société complète he
qui est en danger parce que aujourd'hui
effectivement on protège les écoles on
protège parce qu'on est dans
l'inquiétude he on est en alerte àenttin
faut pasurer mais euh il va falloir que
sur toute la politique générale de ce
pays et on va peut-être en parler et en
particulier sur l'immigration on ait des
gestes fort clair et net on ne peut plus
continuer comme ça on ne peut plus nous
sommes en train notre paix vous savez je
va je juste euh jeudi dernier le
président de la République a pris la
parole euh au lendemain de de ce qui se
passe de manière monstrueuse en Israël
et il a dit une phrase restons unis
restons debout elle a pas de sens cette
phrase elle a pas de sens à le lendemain
il y avait l'assassinat mais restons
unis comment peut-on être uni quand tous
les gens d'un pays quand tous les
habitants d'un pays ne ne partagent pas
les mêmes codes les mêmes valeurs et la
même notion de ce qu'est l'unité d'un
pays voilà donc restons unis cette
phrase moi je la trouve un petit peu
aujourd'hui superficielle et et décalée
on va parler du donons-nous les moyen
d'être uni on va parler du projet de loi
immigration justement il arrive au Sénat
le 6 novembre est-ce que dans le
contexte actuel vous dites il faut qu'on
trouve un accord il faut qu'il y ait un
texte ah mais il faut qu'on trouve un
accord mais ça dépend du gouvernement
aujourd'hui pas que parce que géralin il
vous a quand même beaucoup tendu la main
ces dernier jour non mais il nous a non
mais attendez vous savez très bien que
oui il y a des choses intéressantes dans
ce texte et cetera sauf que dans ce
texte n'est pas écrit la politique
migratoire que l'on veut pour notre pays
c'est bien c'est c'est très important de
renforcer un certain nombre de choses de
réécrire des règles qui sont aujourd'hui
tellement ouvertes que tout le monde
vient personne ne repart parce que c'est
la réalité mais bon mais il veut durcire
ça ce texte il veut faciliter les
expulsions oui oui mais enfin d'abord il
faut n conisse comment il va faire hein
parce que faciliter les explulions on
n'arrive déjà pas à le faire vous savez
je crois que les derniers chiffres qu'on
a c'est 7 % des TF appliqués donc si
vous voulez là là j'ai pas il y a pas un
il y a pas de sujet sur renforçons
soyons beaucoup plus ferme et cetera
mais quelle est la politique migratoire
que nous voulons pour ce pays c'est
voilà c'est c'est ça le sujet c'est ça
le sujet donc il y a des articles sur
lequels nous ne lâcheront pas c'est la
régularisation par le travail vous le
savez ça c'est des lignes rouges sur
lesqueles nous ne lâcherons pas mais
vous lâcherez pas de quelle manière
est-ce que si par que déjà est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas en minorité au Sénat sur
ce sujet ça je vais pas le dire à
l'avance ça c'est pas moi qui peut vous
répondre à ces questions aujourd'hui et
deuxième question est-ce que ne pas
lâcher ça veut dire accepter que ça
passe par une circulaire non mais mais
après si ça passe par une circulaire le
gouvernement expliquera aux Français que
par une circulaire irrégularise sans
papier mais il ne pourra pas compter sur
des bmentaires dont je suis pour
cautionner ça puisque moi je suis est-ce
vous vous voterez le texte si c'est
sorti du texte ah ben alors si c'est
sorti du texte et qu'on regarde tout le
reste du texte la question effecemment
n'est pas la même mais en tout cas sur
ce sujet-là c'est évident en tout cas je
pense que notre groupe ne le votera pas
et moi je ne le voterai pas on peut pas
avoir on peut pas aujourd'hui dans notre
pays à être dans le dénis que nous
n'avons nous avons aujourd'hui une
migration que nous ne gérons plus qui
qui pose des problèmes d'unité qui pose
des problèmes de sécurité c'est une
réalité donc le dénis est pour moi c'est
l'irresponsabilité vraiment hier Gérald
harmanin a dit qu'il voulait intégrer à
ce texte immigration une disposition
permettant de retirer son titre de
séjour à un étranger qui adhère à une
idéologie djihadiste vous soutiendrez
cette mesure ah bah oui bravo bravo elle
vous paraît faisable c'est tout toute la
question toute la question parce que
nous avons aujourd'hui aussi des
tribunaux qui cassent les décisions
l'état quand même hein donc c'est aussi
la question nous avons des associations
qui font tout pour que les décisions de
l'État soient cassées il va fallir aussi
peut-être réfléchir sur ces associations
qui vivent des de dotations de l'État
pour casser les les décisions de l'État
donc il y a une il a il y a du travail à
faire sur ce sujet vraiment on va
continuer à parler de ces questions de
terrorisme et de laïcité puisquehier
vous avez auditionné la sœur de Samuel
Patti Michel Patti dans le cadre de la
commission d'enquête sur les menaces et
agressions contre les enseignants on va
voir les temps forts de cette audition
avec CIV
[Musique]
Jourdan bonjour St bonjouran bonjour
madame la sénatrice bonjour et stvia la
sœur de Samuel paatti était donc
auditionnée par les sénateur c'est une
prise de parole qui dans le texte était
évidemment très attendu oui deuxième
prise de parole cette semaine lundi à
l'occasion des 3 ans de l'assassinat de
son frère Michell paatti s'était déjà
exprimé publiquement à l'occasion d'un
événement autour des défis de l'école
français mais hier l'audition avait un
caractère plus personnel plus intime
plus solennel aussi Michel Patti était
seul devant une commission d'enquête sur
les menaces et agressions contre les
enseignants au mois de mai c'était elle
qui avait sollicité le Sénat pour mettre
en place cette commission objectif faire
toute la lumière sur les éventuelles
défaillances de l'État évidemment hier
dans toutes les têtes il y avait
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard
écoutezla la mort de mon frère sit
quelque chose bon comme vous le savez si
ça avait servver à quelque chose
peut-être que Monsieur Dominique Bernard
sera sera encore là donc je pense
qu'effectivement
euh les mesures n'ont pas du tout été
prises puisque l'affaire de mon frère
n'a absolument pas été analysé et Steve
Michel pati a pointé du doigt les
failles de l'enquête oui elle critique
la manière dont a été conduite l'enquête
de l'inspection générale de l'éducation
nationale à la suite de la mort de son
frère il faut un peu situer peut-être le
le contexte Samuel paatti est assassiné
le 16 octobre 2020 un mois plus tard un
rapport de l'Inspection Générale est
publié il revient sur les jours qui ont
précédé l'assassinat très gros rapport
de 22 pages qui avaient à l'époque
suscité énormément d'émotion Michel
Patti estime que l'enquête qui a
débouché sur ce rapport a été mal
conduite écoutez on s'interrogera sur la
conception très particulre du dialogue
que cette mission d'inspection a pu
avoir avec les acteurs du terrain seuls
trois professeurs sur ont été entendus
sur les 51 qui composent l'équipe
pédagogique versus versus quatre
représentants des parents d'élèves
inversant ainsi le rapport de force et
maintenant c'est effectivement la
question que se posent les sénateurs
comment éviter les drames comment éviter
les tragédies à l'avenir Michel paatti
est revenu sur la nécessité de mieux
former les profs on l'écoute pour tous
ces jeunes professeurs je pense qu'ils
ont une formation tout à fait succinte
par rapport à la laïicité il faut
totalement
réapprofondir la laïcité comme on l'a
toujours connu en France donc pour ça il
faut comme je l'ai un peu demandé c'est
reprendre la main effectivement sur
l'enseignement supérieur pour que
effectivement il y ait un système de
contrôle qui soit mis en place sur ce
qui est fait et comment cela est fait
madame la sénatrice qui ressort de cette
audition c'est que les enseignements
n'ont pas été tirés vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse ce constat de Michel
paaty oui et et tristement j'ai envie de
dire le cette audition hier elle était
forte je sais pas enfin vous avez
assisté comme moi à cette audition elle
était très forte elle a posé des choses
qui doivent interroger quand même des
choses qui n'ont jamais été dites et je
reviendrai sur certains sujets quand
elle parle de la laïcité des enseignants
en particulier des enseignants des
jeunes enseignants elle a totalement
raison elle a totalement raison
Jean-Pierre auin cet inspecteur qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur le sujet
disait lundi soir que je suis allé à la
soirée lundi soir organisé au théâtre
par Michel Paty aussi sur sauvons
l'école disait que parmi les enseignants
qui arrivent aujourd'hui dans les
établissements scolaires il y a une
partie d'entre eux qui ne comprend pas
pourquoi on n'accepte pas la BAA le
voile enfin voilà donc ça inquiète quand
même donc ça veut dire qu'effectivement
on a
aujourd'hui lâché et les enseignants ne
sont pas formés suffisamment à la laïité
en terme de la laïité c'est une chance
c'est elle émancipe la laïcité
aujourd'hui disait effectivement dans
l'udition c'est qu'il y avait une
laïcité dite
ouverte je ne poserai je ne alors la
laïcité elle ne s'adjectif pas c'est
laïcité point donc moi-même je
n'emploirai pas le mot que vous avez
employé pas moi c mais je sais je sais
vous l'avez repris mais moi je veux pas
le reprendre parce que je veux pas le
prononcer parce que la laïcité ne
s'adjective pas c'est la laïcité point
voilà et c'est cette laïcité point qui
est remise en cause au sein même de
l'éducation nationale clairement par des
enseignants donc a tout à fait raison et
tout le monde le point de ça aujourd'hui
les enseignants ne sont pas suffisamment
formés et n'adhèrent pas suffisamment à
cette clité que nous devons préserver
sauver à tout prix ça c'est essentiel et
c'est avec ça que jouent les islamistes
dans l'établissement scolaire les
revendications elles sont aussi posées
par rapport à ça parce que tout le monde
ne va pas dans le même sens elle a dit
quelque chose d'important aussi hier
elle a dit que les renseignements
territoriaux avaient fait des enquêtes
et avait en particulier et ça ça m'a
profondément
interrogé et inquiété
euh tenu compte d'un rapport qui avait
été écrit et rédigé par un pseudo
médiateur qui avait été utilisé le
Conseil des musulmans des ivelines c'est
que l'État s'appuie sur des médiateurs
religieux pour se faire une idée sur la
médiation qui peut avoir lieu sur des
sujets comme cela mais c'est juste une
honte c'est ENF l'État qui s'appuie sur
des représentant religieux pour savoir
si tout va bien et si le climat est
apaisé mais c'est juste pas le rôle de
l'État en dire nous sommes dans une
enfin c'est c'est moi ça m'a extrêmement
choqué que des religieux s'imissent sur
ce genre de sujet et que on tienne
compte de leur avis pour dire bah
finalement tout est calme ENF on va
régler le problème et ça va s'apaiser ça
n'a pas d'abord premièrement c'éta faut
deuxièmement ça c'est pas apaaisé et
troisièmement samuelpti a été égorgé
donc vraiment là vraiment il y a quelque
chose chose qui m'interroge sur la
manière dont on a posé ce problème au
sein enfin dans dans ce département
vraiment et et c'est grave et c'est
grave vraiment est-ce qu'il y a aussi
des interrogations j'imagine que oui
hein sur la la manière dont le problème
a été posé à l'école parce qu'après le
cours de Samuel paatti la la principale
a reçu des plaintes de parents d'élèves
elle a demandé à Samuel paatti de
s'excuser vous savez ça c'est juste
scandaleux d'abord elle a demandé à
s'excuser elle a convoqué les parents la
menteuse parce que moi je l'appelle la
menteuse voilà quand même c'est l'élève
juste pour qu'on précise c'est l'élève
qui disait qu'elle était présente au
cours alors qu'elle avait séché et que
Samuel Patti avait pointé du doigt les
musulmans VO et qui sait le père de
cette jeune fille tout le monde sait
tout le monde sait qui tout le monde
savait qui était le père de cette jeune
fille il était connu pour cet islamisme
fou il était connu et donc on met sur le
même plan un enseignement un enseignant
qui fait son cours et le père d'une
élève qui a menti qui t un islamiste
dangereux je dire que la principale a
reçu avec qui elle a dialogué sans même
savoir que sa fille avait séché le cours
exactement première voilà première chose
et vous savez lundi soir au théâtre
c'était intéressant parce que Michel
pati elle a retracé la construction
éducative du cours de son frère je vous
assure que c'était impressionnant il a
fait son travail avec les outils
pédagogique que l'éducation nationale
autorise et favorise pour pouvoir
expliquer et démontrer il n'a fait
strictement que son travail dans un
cadre pédagogique qu' a respecté il n'a
fait que ça et je vous assure que dou
son refus de s'excuser aussi parce que
lui disait qu'il avait son travail parce
qu'il a fait il a fait son travail dans
le cadre dans le cadre de l'éducation
nationale dans un cadre pédagogique bien
détaillé bien écrit qui l' a respecté et
on lui demande de s'excuser et cette
professeur il avait ce professeur il
avait quoi comme objectif de de de de de
de tirer les enfants vers le haut de
leur donner cette respiration dont un
adolescent a besoin pour avoir un sens
critique et c'est ça qu'on a tué aussi
c'est ça qu'on a tué à travers Emmanuel
pati et vraiment il faut et elle a eu
raison de dire que si on avait tiré des
conclusions de ça le professeur d'as ne
serait pas mort probablement oui aussi
pour vous la mort de Dominique Bernard
c'est c'est la même chose c'est la même
ça veut direon pas tiré les conclusions
c'est la même idéologie c'est au nom de
la même cause et c'est avec les mêmes
méthodes et ce ce ce ce ce criminel cet
islamiste d' race il cherchait un prof
d'histoire ne l'oublions pas l'histoire
elle permet aussi cette respiration
d'explication du monde et de réflexion
que les enfants doivent se construire à
l'école au collège et au lycé vraiment
mais aucune leçon n'a été tirée est-ce
que vous avez l'impression parce que la
mort de Samuel paatti elle pose aussi
beaucoup la question du pas de vague
c'était aussi la volonté mais c'est ça
la réalité alors est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
il est encore là ce pas de vague ou
est-ce que vous trouvez qu'il y a plus
de fermeté et que notamment les propos
de Gabriel vous rassure alors les propos
de Gabriel Atal que j'ai évidemment
entendu hier me rassure mais enfin on a
eu une année pas pendaille entre deux
hein quand même entre monsieur Blanquer
et on a eu voilà donc ça veut dire que
le Président de la République quand même
quand même he la responsabilité c'est
quand même le président de la République
Monsieur Atal est un ministre que je
respecte et qui a un discours assez
clair ferme que j'approuve he depuis le
mois de septembre enfin derrière il a le
président de la République qui a passé
son temps à dire oui à dire non et à
donner vouloir donner raison à tout le
monde voilà où on d'Emmanuel Macron ah
ben complètement l'axisme ou décalé ou
qui ne comprend pas alors là il comprend
parce qu'on tient plus rien donc et et
ça remet l'unité de notre pays en cause
aujourd'hui mais Emmanuel VCON il a
quand même enfin jusqu'à présent vous
savez vous le savez moi au Sénat combien
de fois j'ai alerté combien de fois j'ai
bousculé si vous regardez les réponses
du gouvernement que j'ai eu depuis 6 ans
on peut pas dire que c'était un discours
de fermeté on peut pas dire que c'était
un discours qui a prouvait mes propos
que parfois il trouvverit excessif et
bien regardez aujourd'hui les propos de
de de d'Emmanuel je peux me les
approprier parce que ce sont les miens
donc voilà donc oui il y a eu un un
refus de voir la réalité des manel
Macron ça a commencé avec Najad B Val
benkassem sous le président Hollande et
ça a continué là donc voilà c'est 10 ans
de de négation de ce qui allait s'écrire
dans ce pays c'est 10 ans 179 césin du
procureur de la République c'est le
chiffre qu' a donné hier Gabriel Attal
pour des contestations provocation lors
de la minute d'ommage à Dominique
Bernard est-ce que c'est un chiffre qui
vous inquiète alors d'abord c'est un
chiffre officiel de ce qui est remonté
je suis pas sûr que tout soit remonté
entre malgré le fait que Gabriel Atal
est demandé de faire remonter
nominativement je veux y croire mais je
ne suis pas certaine voilà parce que il
y a peut-être dans des établissements
des choses qui ont été dites ou faites
ou que voilà pour lequel établissement
dit que c'était peut-être pas grave ENF
je suis pas sûr que ce soit mais moi je
pense que s'il y en a un c'est un de
trop oui ça m'inquiète oui ça m'inquiète
il y en a probablement moins eu quand
2020 après le décès de de de la mort de
deti mais oui ça m'inquiète parce que
moi s'il y en a un c'est un de trop
vraiment le collège de Samuel pati ne
porte toujours pas son nom contrairement
à la à la promesse d'Emmanuel Macron
lors de son hommage est-ce que c'est la
preuve que la République a plié pour
vous c'est la preuve que des élus des
services n'ont pas de courage je le dis
clairement ne pas vouloir nommer le
collège Samuel pati c'est une absence de
courage et c'est une faiblesse énorme et
je trouve ça scandaleux ah mais je le
dis je l'ai écrit je l'ai j'ai écr je l'
écrit je l'ai dit dans mes propos vous
avez une réponse du gouvernement voir d'
pas que le gouvernement pour le coup là
alors on va être clair parce que moi
j'aime bien la transparence et l'honneté
il y a le maire de la commune il y a le
président du département il y a le
daazen c'est ensemble qu'on se met
autour de la table pour dire oui on va
le faire quand même et non on n pas peur
et oui on va résister et ça c'est pour
l'instant c'est pas posé oua le desen
c'est l'éducation nationale c'est ça ça
veut dire que du coup là aussi il encore
des fa tout m mais voilà mais voilà
c'est c'est et il faut lutter et se dire
que si des parents
d'élèv sont contre si des enseignants
sont contre il faut leur montrer où est
la ligne il est pas mort enfin il est
pas mort par hasard Samuel pati il est
mort parce qu'il y a une éidologie
mortifère qui installe dans notre pays
et bien si on ne lutte pas avec non pas
des symboles mais des gestes forts et
courageux c'est pas la peine de se
battre he donc ça ça en fait partie oui
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du coup de
cette mission sur les les agressions que
vous êtes en train de mener je pense que
cette mission elle doit montrer les
failles et les faiblesses de la manière
dont on gère tous ces sujets
actuellement dans notre dans notre pays
et en particulier à l'école merci
Jacqueline SGE brigot merci beaucoup
d'être venu nous parler de tous ces
sujets ce matin merci Steve à tout à
l'heure tout à l'heure